[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 26th of
October I'm James heel The Spectators
political correspondent and your host
this week coming up on the
show why is the West so confused about
the war in Israel why don't people know
which side to back yes Shaman will be
joining the show later it's been nearly
3 weeks since Hamas attacked Israel on
the 7th of October Uzi arid will give us
the latest on the conflict Katy balls
will be on the show to talk about Rich's
first year in power and Michael wrid
will tell us what to expect from next
week's AI Summit in Bley Park and Kate
Andrews explains why she recently tried
smoking again I'd also like to thank our
sponsors canor genuity wealth management
experienced wealth planners and
investment managers who offer unwavering
support during challenging times to find
out more visit C do wealth for more
information before we get going if you
like spectator TV do subscribe to our
YouTube channel thousands are joining
our Channel every week and you should be
one of them just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss
another episode first up yam monk author
of the identity trap writes this week's
cover piece the West he says doesn't
know which side to back in the war in
Israel and Gaza to explain Yasha joins
me now Yasha you right in this week's
magazine that the reaction to the
atrocities committed in Israel is
different to the reaction of those in
other countries tell us why yeah it's a
really striking contrast when you think
of the difference in reaction to
something like 911 in the world in which
was big protest of solidarity with the
United States lont titled we are all
Americans um in the aftermath of the
worst terrorist attack on Jewish life
since World War II the slaughter of over
400 people many of them babies
grandmothers by Hamas uh we didn't see
anything like that um Lamont talked
about Israel's Lust For Revenge um we
saw plenty of protests in the Streets of
London and Paris and Berlin and so on uh
but they were uh
supporting uh uh the Palestinian course
but more specifically in many cases
glorifying those uh uh Hamas fighters
who who carried that that murder now
part of that is of course this is one
particular uh episode in a broader uh
political conflict but is very
complicated and reasonable people can
have very different views about why for
example um we are so far from peace
today and that has I think led to a lack
of moral Clarity in some journalists who
want to complicate individual episodes
in this conflict um even if those are
morally absolutely clear you can can
have different views about Isel
Palestine you should not be able to have
different views intellectually and
morally about the permissibility of this
uh terrible terrorist attack but there
is also something broader here and that
is rooted in a new ideology a new set of
ideas about race gender and sexual
orientation a new set of ideas about
Concepts like structural racism and
intersectionality and what it means to
be postcolonial that I trace in my new
book the identity trap and that I wrote
about in the magazine this week and you
write that this is grounded in the
changing nature of the left uh in the
ideas being taught in universities in
the academy tell us about this kind of
intellectual development of this new
movement this new ideology as you put
it yeah so more broadly it's it's it's a
new set of ideas about the role that
identity categories do and should play
in our society
um I call it the identity trap because
there's a lure here which is to
recognize the ways in which our
societies whether in the United Kingdom
or the United States or France or other
places are unjust um uh still do show
the signs of uh previous injustices in
particular and so these ideas claim to
be the most radical the most
uncompromising way to fight against
first injustices to Build a Better World
the problem is that they are a trap they
actually encourage the kind of zero some
conflict that as we're seeing in Israel
Palestine at the moment can lead to
terrible Bloodshed they're making it
harder rather than easier for us to
construct a peaceful and tolerant
society in which we have real political
solidarity with each other across the
lines of those groups now one of the
problems with it that ends up being
really relevant in this debate is that
it doesn't allow us to see the world
very clearly
um you know uh many people on the left
have taken on an exclusively structural
understanding of racism in which if
you're part of a
supposedly uh uh marginalized group it
is impossible for you to have prejudices
against to be racist against a member of
a supposedly dominant group because
we've thrown the older conception of
racism based on individual bias
completely out of the window there's a
superimposition in a sort of neocolonial
way of American racial categories on
everybody else so when people analyze
something like the Israel Palestine
conflict they try to fit Jews into the
box of white people and Palestinians
into the box of people of color and so
even though at this point a plurality of
Israelis are misrahi Jews who were
thrown out of Middle Eastern countries
in violent ways over the course of the
last 75 years and have a very similar
skin tone to Palestinians they are
perceived as white who are part of this
dominant group uh that therefore cannot
have bad things happen to them and
Palestinians are coted as people of
color who therefore must be justified in
their resistance there's an imposition
of the categories of settler colonies on
Israel so that uh uh you know Israelis
are seen in the same way in which uh U
you know the Americans who arrived in
North America on the Mayflower are seen
as these kind of outsid settlers who
come in even though of course Jews trace
the origins to the Middle East to uh uh
the teritory of today's uh uh Israel as
to Palestinians um and again a lot of
the population are people like Mahi Jews
who flew from Middle Eastern countries
who did not have anywhere else uh to go
and so we're seeing how these simplistic
ways of squeezing everything in into
identity categories are not just making
it harder to understand the world but
then result in these very significant
moral errors like claiming that uh these
terrorist attacks are Justified because
all Israeli civilians are settlers who
have it coming to basically yes and I
suppose in that answer there you talk
more about the Israelis and how they're
perceived but there's also quite a
patronizing undertone to how the
Palestinians are achieved in this I
suppose is that your argument is that a
lot of the Western View and Western
interpretation under this new thinking
produces quite a patronizing account of
how the Palestinian authorities conduct
themselves in a way in which it almost
excuses their agency in all of
this yeah I
mean you know one of the elements we
haven't quite touched on is the concept
of
intersectionality which suggests that
all forms of Oppression are somehow
naturally linked um and so you have
these weird placards at many prop
Palestinian protests saying things like
uh you know Reproductive Rights depend
on Palestine or queers for Palestine um
and if you then point out um that
actually uh uh gay and despian in Baza
strip are sent to jail for 10 years uh
that Hamas openly just an islamist
organization all openly uh criminalizes
uh homosexuality um then the Defenders
of that organization start to say uh
well but that isn't really the for of
Palestinians Owen Jones pointed out that
the first time that homosexuality was
criminalized was under the British
mandate uh uh you know decades ago this
is a great example of robbing
Palestinians of agency because just as
Britain changed its laws about
homosexuality in the you know 80 plus
years since the British mandate on
Palestine uh went away Hamas today would
be very open and very free and very able
to stop criminalizing
homosexuality uh if they felt like it
right to to ascribe this to uh sort of
the actions of British colonialists who
certainly have done bad things in the
world um is to pretend that Palestinians
don't have any agency today in execu way
that you point out and I've got to ask I
mean this Narrative of intersectionality
it's been pushed by uh queers for
Palestine presumably Palestine for
queers isn't pushing the reverse and
that this is basically just a one-way
Western narrative rather than one which
is reciprocated and returned in kind by
the
Palestinians yeah I think that's right
and what's what's sort of interesting
and strange about it is just how
simplistic that view of a world is um so
you know the concept of
intersectionality was coined by Kimberly
cran Shaw to make a sensible point which
is that the Discrimination for example
that a black woman might experience in
United States is more than just the
arithmetic sum of the disadvantage faced
by white women on the one side and black
men on the other side and that I think
is true but the way that that concept
has then been interpreted is to go well
beyond that so say that if you stand at
a different intersection of identities
from me when I can't really understand
you that therefore all forms of
Oppression are linked and if you want to
be an activist in good stand on one
issue like environmentalism for example
you have to defer to and accept the
political positions of all of these
other groups as well so to be a good
environmentalist you also have to have a
particular understanding of feminism and
you also have to have a particular
understanding of trans rights and you
also have to have a particular
understanding of uh What uh sort of a
right answer to the Palestine conflict
is um and you're right that that in a
strange way ends up going uh in one way
um but I think PR era is that the world
is just more complicated than that that
there can be uh groups that are allies
in one context and uh not allies in
another context um that groups that uh
perhaps have experienced real
disadvantage and marginalization in one
context nevertheless want to turn around
and oppress and marginalize others in a
different
context and you make the point of course
that we're going to see these Dynamics
only become more inflamed and
intensified in the coming weeks and
years you referen in your piece this
letter signed by um 1700 sociologists so
you expecting that as the conflict
continues and potentially we've
discussed elsewhere on this uh show
about having a ground Invasion do you
think this is only going to become more
and more of a theme in the West's left
arguments yes I feel so I mean we've
already seen how this conflict has uh uh
not just uh claim for lives of a lot of
uh innocent people in in Israel and in
Gaza um but and this is less important
but significant nevertheless we've seen
how it's led to uh these very nasty
fights in in Britain and United States
and and and and
elsewhere um you know we've seen
institutions uh respond in a very cowly
way um to the initial Hamas attack uh
you know universities in particular that
have gotten in the habit over the course
of the last five years of commenting on
anything that's happening in the world
of condemning anything that they dislike
suddenly for conspicuously silent uh
when the worst massacre of Jews since
the Holocaust took place um and then
when these institutions uh were forced
by public pressure to make statements
about this as they have about everything
else there was a huge counter reaction I
mean hundreds and thousands of um uh
students and and and faculty members
faulting the university for speaking out
in this kind of way um and uh I feel
that as the the conflict in the Middle
East looks Set uh to escalate um that uh
warn campus and in many other
institutions is going to escalate as
well yesha thank you so much for joining
us on spectator TV today thank you so
much Israel is still building up forces
on the border with Gaza is the plan
still on for a ground Invasion if so why
hasn't it happened yet I'm joined Now by
Uzi arid a former National Security
advisor to Benjamin
Netanyahu Uzi thanks for joining us on
spectator TV Israel is still building up
ground forces near Gaza there's talk of
a grand Invasion but the IDF have said
something different could be coming what
are you expecting in the next few days
of the
conflict well indeed uh the option of
having an incursion or what is called in
uh the Israeli language a ground
maneuver is still on the table uh the
war cabinet has to decide on this next
step and it hasn't yet so it is not near
as I can tell it's not imminent and at
the current time uh priority is given to
some extent to the hostage uh issue
Netanyahu seems to be blaming the
military for what happened on the 7th of
October
and Israeli journalists like anel Fifer
I say military are blaming Netanyahu for
being too slow to make a decision on the
next stage of the war who do you think
is to blame here well there is plenty of
blame for all concerned uh there is no
lack of it clearly and you cannot deny
the facts that we were taken by surprise
by this uh very vicious and
overwhelmingly cruel attack on our
civilians and the surprise is undeniable
uh although as always is the case uh in
postmortem then you always discover that
there were Advance warning that it was
ignored things of that nature but all
this will be learned after after the war
uh the
military uh the intelligence
Community had and their heads have very
very um in a noble way uh come forward
and said we are
responsible but and it is undeniable
that we had mishaps both in the military
part of it and the intelligence early
warning part of it but saying we are
responsible does not indicate how flawed
they were and whether they accept blame
but they know they essentially know that
they'll be called to task um there were
also other senior office uh officials
who said that they were and they
consider themselves uh responsible the
only one who has refused to say so is
the prime minister and there is a
growing expectation and demand of him to
do the same because in so many ways uh
what he may be guilty of is not that he
is the head of the intelligence he's the
head of the military but also that he is
the architect of the policies uh which
have turned out to be completely flawed
he is uh responsible for the approach
that sought to cultivate the Hamas
rather than destroy it he was not
truthful uh to his original commitment
to say that he'll fight Kamas actually
he dealt with Kamas so his respons his
responsibility is overwhelming political
ministerial uh and has of the executive
and and yet he's the only one who
refuses to say even that he made a a
mistake and that is causing much
agitation in Israel now so given that
agitation given that
responsibility do you think once the war
is concluded that will be the end of
Netanyahu a politician who of course has
been written off many times
before you know as I said he was already
uh on a very risky position before this
huge event because he's been uh standing
trial for corruption uh charges he has
been fighting uh his own efforts to to
rid himself of of this thing led to what
was called the judicial reform which was
hotly debated and I even I told his
National Security advisor uh days before
this recent Gaza attack that he has the
most difficult job I can remember as
head of the NC not only because his
prime minister is beleaguered by so many
accusations but because he essentially
functions like a lame duck he was a lame
duck beforehand and with this
blow what you know in historical terms
is essentially finished talk us through
the war cabinet here uh how much do we
know about the discussions going on
inside that and the different positions
adopted by the members of it well we've
established this new setup which we call
the war cabinet so as to have more than
one or two people managing the war
itself the management of the war because
the full cabinet the cabinet is the one
which is authorized to make decisions
but the daily running executing the war
has been delegated to a group of five or
six which consist of the Prime Minister
the defense minister two generals from
the opposition uh his foreign policy
advisor and then a politician now there
all presumably their discussions are
secret and there is no point in
highlighting them but already there is
much leaks and some are authoritative
leaks and it is clear that there may be
some uh debates inside and the debates
are narrow probably around the issue
about prioritizing when when to
undertake this uh ground maneuver if at
all uh how to deal with the uh hostage
issue at what pace um and and what is
complicating the matter is that most of
the members of this cabinet are
themselves people when the war ends will
have to give a lot of explaining because
they were flawed and it is not an easy
psychological political even ethical
position to be to manage the war when
you have this kind of of burden on you
yet they have to do it and presumably
they're doing it turning our attentions
to the International Community what's
the sense in Israel about how the world
feels about all this conflict just
coming off the back of what the UN
Secretary General said this week
suggesting that the attacks by Hamas did
not happen in a vacuum are there fears
in Israel that the country could lose
the sport of a lot of the Western
Community uh if it wages a long
difficult war against tamas in
Gaza yes uh such concern existed in fact
uh all of us knew that uh the world
would be simply shocked by the savagery
of the uh of the atrocities committed by
Hamas and that this impact and the way
it impacted on public opinion so forth
would gain us some sympathy uh due to
the terrible price we paid uh innocent
Israelis and the cruelty which is simply
uh impossible to stain and the
realization possibly that Hamas is an
Isis like being it is not the usual uh
combatant in the Middle East which
employs Terror here and there this is
Terrorism on a scale unknown and it is
directed not only against Israel so we
gained sympathy but we knew that it
would dissipate and uh that we had so so
much time uh to take action and now the
dissipation is taking place because of
the
inevitability of the situation on the
ground when the Hamas is taking the
civilian population of Gaza as as human
shelters they are hiding behind and they
are exposing them and in our desire not
to have civilians hurt in the future
engagement we have there has been some
displacement of Palestinians and
humanitarian concerns came to the for
all these has to be dealt with and
clearly we have to be very careful but
we have to manage a war we have to
accomplish this destruction of Kamas
once and for all but then what comes at
the margins of that is the same old
anti-semitic sentiment that we have
encountered here and there and is an
inevitable fact of history and including
political life and that's a Pity because
you would expect people to be more
sensitive and and less uh less uh rush
to condemnation of Israel in a most
simplistic
way and today there was a meeting um
some of the leaders of Hamas Hezbollah
and Islamic jih had they had been
discussing reports of setting reports
ways to win a real Victory against
Israel How concerned to you about the
potential of Lebanon to get involved in
all of this and another front opening up
uh in the war against
Israel well that too could have been
expected that with this relative success
of of of Hamas just like the relative
successes of Isis at the time when they
overran the Middle East uh and had
accomplishment uh it was expected that
some would either exploit the situation
uh for their uh interest uh could it
Beal it has his own and other radical
extremist Muslim uh extremist and so
forth and it is a problem because they
may perceive that Israel's military
alertness had subsided and they may be
tempted
uh it is against that that the US
president uh delivered his essentially
his ultimatum and he said it very very
clearly he said if there were any third
parties hinting atalah possibly
elliptically also at Iran should there
be any third party which would seek to
exploit this moment and to intervene uh
thinking that it is an opportunity they
shouldn't and I think that this phrase
that they should hinted that they may
have to pay a price this is what we have
to do to bolster our deterrents which
had been
damaged uh and so should we if if
anybody would seek to exploit it well
they will help have to confront uh the
residual capacity of Israel to act and
our residual capacity is not
negligible you mentioned there third
party actors third States involved in on
this yesterday Saudi Arabia brought down
a missile we think was either Iranian or
yemeni aimed at Israel how is the
relationship between Israel and the
Saudi Arabia in light of everything
that's
happened well yeah I can't really tell
because things are very fluid and I
don't know what transpires in
negotiations but clearly the Americans
in their very active diplomacy here in
the region and not only the Americans
Europeans maybe the country as well and
so forth uh um have been dealing with
all parties in the Gulf uh all concerned
parties each seeking their own uh
interest but what is now becoming clear
however that in Regional
terms um we are essentially confronting
let's say the Western group of Nations
but it's not only Western confronting a
block of
radical uh countries which would consist
in this case of Iran and the yemenites
and uh Syria possibly and Lebanon which
is under their influence and using all
those practices which promote Iranian
interest in the region and even Beyond
so it is a semi Global contest and uh
they are UND the offensive they would
probably activate may not do so in a
grand offensive but they are expected to
move more aggressively all over the all
over the region and this is a problem
that we will have to confront those of
us who are Allied on the same side and
Qatar has played a role in mediating for
the Israeli hostages but of course for a
long time they hosted hamas's leadership
what is your perception of Qatar and all
of this I mean they've got a huge amount
of investment here in the UK strong ties
what how is Israel reacting to what
qatar's involvement has
been well you know uh uh Middle East
politics are byzantin historically they
always have been and now with all those
complicating interest uh some of them
become very odd bad fellows but Qatar is
the most perplexing of them all because
in a way it is dancing on all camps it
is not wholly evil but it is not wholly
good and it is playing its own games in
so many ways uh Qatar by and large had
been financing this uh buildup of Kamas
uh and it is bankrolling it and in that
sense it should have been considered a
negative presence but at the same time
it is in contact with others and so and
with us to uh here and there they serve
the useful service of being mediators or
Bridges and that that function uh is not
again not unimportant at this very
moment the Israeli NC Chief even went
public thanking the Qatari government so
I think this would be our approach we
would want to see Qatar less involved on
the bad side more involved on the good
side but its game is still very
complicated Uzi thank you so much for
joining me today on spectat
TV thank you very
much Richie Sak has been prime minister
for a year how's that year gone I'm
joined Now by Katy RS now Katie this
week it's one year since Rich entered
number 10 how's he doing I think the
polls speak for themselves in the sense
that his personal approval ratings are
at a worst place than they were this
time last year um the As for the Tory
lead I mean I think he quite quickly
managed to take it down from around 30p
point lead for labor to around a 20
point lead but then since then it's
really stagnated and I think you had
that brief Springtime fishi moment where
lots of people say you know Springtime
recovery and then I think since the
local elections it's been quite hard
goinging and he's caught a break here
and there but really the general
electoral picture has not changed so I
think if you want to probably try and
find some reasons to be positive for
richy sua because he looks back on his
past 12 months um certainly I think
British politics feels Karma the Tory
party feels Karma yes there are
rebellions people you know who are not
huge fans of rishy cak but we definitely
moved away I think from
that mode of almost crisis mode
government where wiconsin talk about
letters whether it's was under Boris
Johnson whether it was under Liz truss
to a more stable form of government the
problem for richy suak is it just feels
as though while he can take some credit
for that it's not cutting free in a way
the public thinks that he deserves
credit and perhaps that's because the
general public thinks that it's you know
the the basic right really to have a
functioning government and you mentioned
in this week's column um the ways in
which the conservatives are trying to
turn this around was quite interesting
anecdote you had from last week's
political C cabinet in which one of the
strategists came in and contrasted one
of the B elections before 1996 which was
South Staffordshire and then the recent
twith B elction uh and contrasting the
turnout in that so really it seems to be
that energizing the Tory voters is how
the conservatives think they can win
next year yes so this was a meeting
happened this week on Tuesday morning
and uh ultimately that's after the
byelection losses last week um which I
think John Curtis the polling experts
you know one of the worst nights for any
governing party in terms of byelection
results two very safe seats in mid
Bedford sh and Tamworth both went labor
and since then you've had lots of you
know analysis saying labor Landslide
Blair era yesterday I was at a book
launch for a member of The Shadow
cabinet and lot going around saying it
feels like 1996 and you can start to
feel I think partly because of those
by-election results people starting to
think and what Isaac lva the election
strategist put to ministers around that
table is before you go straight for
those and this isn't his exact wording
but I think the point of that example
was before you go to the straight you
know we're back in 1996 territory if you
look at the byelection that happened and
what was the to we seat before it was
renamed it was a much higher turnout
then and therefore there are some reads
across for sure but if the Tories can
find a way to get their voters out the
result could be quite different now of
course how you get your voter out is the
big question and that's where I think it
probably gets a bit less Rosy for the
Tory party because speaking to MPS you
know some say oh well it be a choice
between kir starm and rishy sunak and
people don't want kir starma so we'll
get more of our voters out but I think
because K St does not seem scary to lots
of Voters perhaps in the way Jeremy
Corbin did I don't think there' be they
can't really rely on that alone so are
there some more things they can do
between now and the election which
perhaps aren't so much we're talking
about how you get get to a point where
richy Sak is winning another majority
but at least you're avoiding what is
potentially quite a bad Tory wipe out
what coming up the King speech and of of
course the last time we had one was a
queen speech it was May 2022 and I think
the focus of that was leveling up and my
God how much has changed in the 18
months since I mean what are we likely
to see over the next couple of weeks got
that and then I think 10 days later
we've got the um Autumn statement in
terms of themes so I think in the King
speech big focus on energy and crime I
think when it comes to richy sen team
yes they keep some announcements close
to their chest but they're also ones for
being quite you know clear about what is
coming up um and therefore you know
there's a big debate at the moment for
example where there'll be a conversion
therapy ban bill in the King speech um I
think that where they do something
that's quite you know controversial on
different sides of the Tory party and
perhaps that You' go about in a
different way than putting it in the
King speech but that's still one to
watch um then Autumn statement you have
all these Tory MPS pushing for tax cuts
you have Jake Barry's pledge saying that
stop any tax Rises and so been
interesting intentions there but I'd be
very surprised if Rich you know the tax
cuts I think they ultimately don't think
that now there is is a space for it if
you do get to them it's next year and
then you potentially have a reshuffle I
think likely before the end of the year
could it come a bit sooner and the
argument was always do after party
conference um because they wanted Party
Conference to be a much calmer Affair
than the Liz trust year where everyone
is obviously battling one another um and
there's a bit of a push at the moment
from Tor MPS and you know former
ministers to kind of raising concerns
about Jeremy Hunt which isn't a
completely new thing there's been rumors
for a while that Jeremy Hunt we Face the
act as Chancellor and I don't think what
hasn't helped that is a story over the
weekend suggesting he might not contest
his seat at the next election hunt has
since sought to suggest he will do that
but I think the combination of a few of
these things means that you're hearing
not just I would say from the right of
the party but in these conversations
increasingly people saying you know it's
not I have a problem with Jeremy Hunt I
just think that if cost of living is
going to dominate the next election we
need someone full of energy very focused
on comms and getting their message out
there and is Jeremy Hunt the right
choice however even were that to happen
I personally would be very surprised if
it happened in a reshuffle in a couple
of weeks time I think if you move chance
like given the state of where lots of
things are potentially next spring is
more likely it's not to say it won't
happen um but I think this idea you know
if there's a reshuffle in two weeks time
Jeremy Hunt will go as probably wishful
thinking inspired by favorite line of
your comment this week when she said
that the the the Applause to Mar rak's
first year in Downing Street there was
loud banging on the cabinet table led by
Jeremy Hunt so interesting in that
respect um showing he supports his boss
exactly exactly and the boss supports
him um we talked a lot about the Tories
where are we at on labor and Israel and
Palestine so I think what's really
interesting is you would think after
those bi election results lab would be
cocka hoop this week and actually in all
the conversations I've had they just
keep saying oh it's been a very
difficult week and that's across the
party and it all goes down to Israel
Palestine and a r that's been slowly
building over the past couple of weeks
about kiss st's handling of the conflict
now labor conference I think both you
and myself James would say on our
podcast wow look how United the labor
party is no one's you know we had our
colleague John I think go to every
single Israel Palestine event just to
see if there was you know labor disunity
but they they held the line where it
started to go wrong for K sta is he gave
an interview to LBC at the conference
where he was asked about you know you're
saying Israel has a right to defend
herself does that include um Israel
cutting off water and electricity to
Gaza and in the interview he appeared to
suggest that it did since then he sought
to clarify the comments to suggest
that's not what he's meant but he's lost
over 25 labor CS to this now that on
Oxford labor Council there's not even a
majority for the labor anymore because
they've lost so many and there's lots of
discomfort I think in the labor party
parts of the Shadow cabinet potentially
too um he went to mosque I think as a
way to try and calm tensions and put out
a statement it backfired and the mosque
I think in a statement from them it
seems as though those present felt
almost they being used for a bit of a PR
opportunity as opposed to hear their
real concerns um and now you know you're
hearing somewhere on resignation watch
now we might not get to the point of
actual resignations but the fact K has
had to meet with some of his Muslim MPS
try and explain his position I think
does point to trouble ahead for him
because the the feeling amongst these
MPS is that he's got the balance wrong
and he is not being supportive enough of
Palestine there is a balance to be
struck and therefore you have a
situation where Muslim voters um could
just not turn out for the labor party
and you could also you know split parts
of your party and and ultimately this
conflict is very likely to get a lot
worse um if you think about the coming
weeks the fact there's not been a ground
Invasion yet something that the Israeli
government say they are still planning
to do
and I think that will further test K
dama you know trying to on the one hand
show support for Israel to show that you
know in the past the anti-semitic
allegations against labor are no longer
the case while also um showing that he
can be you know a humanitarian voice um
and compassion for the people of
Palestine and I think that is going to
get harder and harder to do the one ray
of light I suppose for K politically is
America have now also talked that you
know temporary not a ceasefire which
seist party want but temporary pauses to
allow Aiden and the UK government will
tend to follow the US line klam wants to
sound and sync with the you know us and
so forth on this but I don't think it
completely gets them out of the B he is
currently in thank you Katie for joining
us on spect
TV next week the UK will host an
international Summit to discuss
artificial intelligence is there a way
to develop the technology without
endangering the human race I'm join now
by Professor Michael wridge from the
University of
Oxford Mike next week the UK hosts an
international AI Summit AT Bletchley
Park before we get on to that and the
purpose of the summit what did you make
of prime minister richi's speech
today uh I think it was a it was a bold
and ambitious step uh for the UK uh I
think it's um interesting that the it's
the UK that's taking the lead
internationally on AI safety we've
historically always had a very strong AI
presence uh in terms of research in the
UK of course we have World leading
companies like deep mine based in in
London the founders of artificial
intelligence and a lot of the main
movers and shakers historically have
been UK based going all the way back to
Alan churing which of course is The
Bletchley um connection um but uh great
to see the UK taking the lead on AI
safety as well and uh looking ahead to
next week's Summit what do you make of
the chance of that having some success
in trying to get a global consensus
around all this it's going to be a
challenge uh I think the uh there are
many complexities with contemporary
artificial intelligence uh one of the
most problematic areas uh when dealing
with AI is that actually it's very
difficult to predict where you're going
to be in two years time there's a huge
Divergence of opinion within the AI
Community about where the technology is
going and how quickly it's evolving uh
and so it's just very difficult to know
you're you're trying to um formulate
plans in an area where there is just
huge uncertainty but I think if we can
uh if we can agree some uh some key
principles and get some common consensus
around the idea of moving forward on AI
safety then that will be uh that will be
a starting point Richie was asked today
about China and obviously extending that
invitation to China we don't know for
the next week's Sumit we don't know yet
if China is going to accept or not but
to what extent is there a different
conversation going on different parts of
the world around AI obviously we've
discussed today about what the UK is
focusing on in terms of safety um and
we're pretty familiar with what's going
on in the US but how are China and other
countries around the world getting
involved in the AI
discussion so everybody's talking about
regulation um and even though we use the
same words when we talk about regulation
they mean different things in different
parts of the world so for example in the
US when the regulation is very driven by
the need to support Innovation and
protect Innovation uh and uh and and
lightweight regulation if it's if it's
required whereas in the EU for example
uh the proposed regulation is very human
rights driven it's very driven around
protecting our data uh and and so on um
so there are there are there are
different models and China I think is is
signaling its willingness to engage and
I think that's really good um uh
formulating a on size fits all set of
regulations seems to me to be a little
bit implausible um not a politician so I
don't have to try and make that work but
I think we might have to accept that
different different parts of the world
are going to look at uh look at the
problem in different ways but I
certainly I think for the for for the uh
for for the for for the liberal
democracies of the world um uh taking
the lead on uh protecting our rights uh
ensuring uh as much as possible AI
development is done safely and
responsibly I think those will be those
will be good steps forward the UK set up
this AI task force modeled on cap
bingham's coid task force what do you
make of that is it the right
approach so I think the um my guess is
that the response to use that model was
really driven by the fact that things
are just moving very quickly and with
the with the with the vaccine task force
the whole point was just look let's
let's not follow the normal Civil
Service models of how we set things up
because we just got to move quickly and
I think that that seems to me to be the
rationale in this case um things have
evolved very very quickly over the last
few years in AI the truth is um the
technology has evolved at a pace that we
genuinely didn't expect we are in a
place with you know the The Landmark
systems like chat GPT and Co where we
didn't expect to be they're much more
competent than we expected them to be at
this stage and so there is some urgency
to move to move forward and that seems
to me to be the rationale for adopting
the task force model yeah the task force
has been given 100 million I mean put
those that figure in context for us is
that going to be enough money really to
look at all the research given as you
say how rapidly developing the
technology seems to be it's a starting
point it's nothing more than a starting
point and I think it's it's important to
bear in mind that this is not something
where you can just tick the box and
think that it's done it's going to be an
evolving landscape and you know in two
years time if we have this conversation
again we're going to be looking at AI
systems which are capable in ways that
we didn't expect today so it's we're
going to need to keep our eye on the
ball uh and uh and and follow it going
forward so I think it's a starting point
I don't think I don't think it's
realistic to expect that we can throw
100 million pounds at this and then it's
done that isn't going to be the case
what are some realistic achievable ways
to we could limit to the dam the
development of dangerous
AI so I think there are a few there are
a few um areas where um where we can
sensibly uh start to look at so for
example there's one which has been very
widely discussed in the AI Community
called the the touring red flag law and
the idea here is that we should never
release AI that basically pretends to be
a human that is if we're interacting
with an AI system whether it's to your
bank or the NHS or anywhere else it
should always be absolutely clear to us
that we're not talking to a human being
and I think that is a very simple core
principle it doesn't seem contentious to
me doesn't seem hard to accept and I
think we we will'll make the world a
better place you know so that's one
example another example that we're
seeing a lot of discussion of at the
moment is around the data that's used to
build these these models and issues of
copyright and intellectual property and
a lot of authors are very angry that
their work has been absorbed by these
these these large AI systems basically
without any kind of permission from them
uh and so on so we need to we're not
looking at traditional copyright law
here um because these Works aren't
literally being copied or we're not
looking at derivative works of them so
we've got to think of new ways and new
laws around that but these are sort of
some concrete examples around um uh
around how we could start to develop uh
AI regulation to protect us got a piece
in this week's magazine by James
Phillips who co-created area um worked
at number 10 for a few years under Boris
Johnson he says that AI has the power to
damage Society um sorry AI that has the
powers to damage Society is being
created by people who know the risks but
are locked in a race against each other
unable to slow down because they worry
about becoming irrelevant is that how
you see it
too so I do think we need to um take
Silicon Valley pronouncements about how
amazing they are with with a little
pinch of salt I mean these companies
have a very big interest in bigging up
what they do and and telling us how
amazingly powerful and cool their
technology is so we do have to we do
have to you know filter uh these things
a little bit um I I think the he is
absolutely right in the in the general
gist of his argument that you know that
we are at a point now where regulation
is going to be required I mean I think
that that I think is accepted the big
issue is what is going to look like what
is that that regulation going to look
like what is an appropriate model for
regulation one concern I have is around
the proliferation of the technology it's
going to be much easier to regulate if
there are a small number of actors and
there for example you know if it's just
open Ai and Microsoft and Google and so
on who are releasing these models then
we can certify them we can subject them
to a barrage of tests and have some
confidence about their capabilities but
if everybody could download one of these
to their smartphones which isn't
possible yet and it's not clear whether
it will be possible but if that was
possible we'd be looking at a completely
different regulatory environment and
then um things start to get much more
complex so proliferation is going to be
is going to be a challenge there prime
minister today referred to UK
intelligence reports and assessments
suggesting a whole range of things that
AI could lead to in terms of risks they
range from fraud uh potentially even you
know child sexual abuse images uh all
even you know he raised the possibility
of human extinction I mean how which of
these risks should be most worried about
and how worried are you about them
obviously the thing that grabs the
headlines is all you human extinction
Etc but how much is that a realistic
Prospect so I think there's two let's
separate out two sets of issues there
are some which I think are absolutely
uncontentious that are immediate that
we're looking at right now so what are
those so for example we've got elections
coming up in the UK and the US in the
next 18 months one really big risk
is that social media in particular just
gets flooded by AI produced
disinformation and uh it can be
personalized down to the level of an
individual uh it can be tailored to an
an individual's particular political
tastes uh and and so on and it can even
be tailored down to the level of using
the language that that individual might
relate to so for example the language of
a teenager in Middlesboro or the
language of a a a wealthy a wealthy
homeowner in the home counties and so on
and uh I don't see at the moment any
genuine barriers to prevent that
happening the technology is there it
genuinely exists right now ai can do
that we can do sentiment analysis on on
people's social the views that people EX
on on social media and then we can use
AI to generate disinformation uh uh uh
directly targeted at them there are
clearly people around the world who
would want to weaponize the technology
in that way who would have a a genuine
interest in disrupting uh the Democratic
processes in the UK the US and so on and
I don't see any great barriers at the
moment so this is something which is
immediate clear and very near to us now
another example of a risk which where we
which is a very genuine one is we know
that this technology is very can produce
very eloquent text very convincing text
but it gets things wrong an awful lot of
the time so uh imagine a teenager who's
got some health condition that they're
embarrassed about they don't want to go
to their doctor or they just don't like
talking to other people so they go on to
one of these large language models and
ask for medical advice and get rubbish
medical advice they get told to drink
bleach or something stupid like that um
and uh I would be genuinely surprised if
we hadn't already seen that scenario
another example is somebody who's
depressed who gets in a conversation and
goes on onto uh on onto a large language
model and the large language model
inadvertently encourag es them to commit
suicide and again there are you know
there's a documented case I believe in
Belgium where this basically happened uh
somebody somebody told the large
language model that they thought maybe
the the best thing they could do for the
world was to kill themselves because
then they'd stop consuming the world's
resources and the language model agreed
with them um so you know and these are
real immediate risks uh and uh need to
be addressed in the very very near term
there's another one that the Prime
Minister referred to and indeed
government have referred to to a number
of times which is a very immediate one
which is the risk of of Cyber attack so
what does that mean um so uh suppose you
want to launch what's called a denial of
service attack on the NHS a denial of
service attack is where you send lots
and lots and lots of of requests to a
worldwide web system and you send them
so quickly that the system can't respond
anymore and and it just it just ceases
to operate um now at the moment uh
launching a denial of a service attack
is not something that an average citizen
can do because it requires some
moderately sophisticated knowledge of
computing technology but powerful AI
potentially makes that that capability
accessible to everybody uh and it means
that all of a sudden you know uh you can
you can have some some some malicious
actor uh who's handed the capability to
launch a denial of service attack on the
NHS or their bank or some other
government services and so on
and so this is where AI is making
possible a whole range of abuses that
simply weren't possible before those
address issues need to be need to be
challenged and while I do believe that
um the providers of this technology
genuinely would like to prevent those
abuses from happening at the moment the
sense I have is that they're patching
their technology by applying gaffet tape
that is somebody finds a way of
persuading a large language model to uh
uh you know to tell people how to build
bombs and so this the the company comes
in and and fixes that one specific flaw
in their system but they all they're
doing there is is the scientific
equivalent of applying a bit of gaffer
tape whenever they see you know whenever
they see holes in the technology we need
much more fundamental Research into
understanding how to how to limit those
abuses and I hope that's what uh the AI
safety Institute that the Prime Minister
announced this morning I hope that
that's the kind of thing that they will
be addressing Mike thank you so much for
joining us on SP
TV and finally Kate Andrews writes in
this week's magazine that she has tried
smoking again after nearly a decade to
tell us why she joins me
now uh Kate you write in the magazine
this week that you recently had a
cigarette for the first time uh tell us
why you did that it was the first time
in in 10 years uh and I've never been a
smoker I decided on my 24th birthday so
9 and a half years ago and that as a as
a Libertarian I should give smoking a
proper go which was a bad idea a really
stupid idea and my body agreed I got
violently ill um and haven't really had
a cigarette since then it's never
something I've been that interested in
doing um but uh government policy is
proving so effective uh but perhaps not
in the way that they were expecting that
it has changed my behavior uh very soon
after Rishi sunak announced at Tory
Party Conference that he was going to
usher in a smoking band for the next
generation of adults uh I decided that
liberal sentiments weren't enough action
needed to be taken and I happened to be
in Paris and I bought a pack of OES and
I had a cigarette so you were truly you
living your principles you know the
point of being a small L liberal is that
you think other people can live
differently from how you live uh that is
the principle and I do try to practice
that and I go into um some points about
myself in the magazine which are a
little bit embarrassing this week about
how truly pathetic I am uh giving some
examples I had to switch to decaf coffee
a very long time ago because caffeine
gives me the shakes uh when I was 19 I I
had a joint with a friend and my poor
father had to come pick me up uh because
I was hysterically crying having a panic
attack uh he laughed at me the entire
way home as I said cigarettes don't
agree with me I do drink but I've I've
never tried to test that past moderation
and genuinely to this day sometimes if I
have a multivitamin it's a toss-up as to
whether or not I'll be sick if I've had
it on an empty stomach I it is
completely embarrassing um so like I'm
desperate to be rock and roll I'm not
I'm but I'm fine for other people to
live their lives pretty much anyway they
want if they're not harming other people
um do I want people to smoke no is
smoking bad yes is it dangerous yes and
the the youngest Generations really seem
to understand this smoking is at an
all-time low for them it seems like it
was being phased out anyway by personal
choice um gen z uh even Millennials you
know everyone recognizes that this stuff
is really bad for you my huge issue is
politicians stepping in and offering up
Nationwide banss on things that you know
are bad for you certainly but I don't
think are any of their business um and
and I think it's a huge overreach
perhaps the biggest we've seen in 13
years of Tory government so far and
that's saying something because they
really have been cracking down on fun
yes I think just the other day I saw a
list of laws that were passed Banning
certain things just between 2012 and
2014 I'd hate to work out how many
things that were legal in 2010 are now
illegal now 2023 um why do you think
that of all the levers the government
can pull so often it seems to be banning
things like this um it's a great
question James because they love to use
the word Freedom when it suits them they
love to Bandy about that word uh they
like to say that they're the party of
Freedom uh and free choice but um
ultimately when you actually press them
on this we see that they more are more
inclined to ban and I I think very often
it's a sense of doing something and but
I do point out in the piece that um you
know I think I think Richie sunak um
really does understand
the concept and also the flaws of
modeling because when he was Chancellor
during the pandemic he was one of the
best ministers on this he recognized
that a lot of the assumptions going into
those models from Sage were were faulty
or not quite right he wanted to see
different scenarios he could not believe
that cost benefit analyses weren't going
on if we look at the models that are
being used for the smoking ban it's a
lot of the same tricks it's faulty
assumptions going in every scenario
makes the assumption that this policy is
needed to eradicate smoking again this
doesn't line up with the current trend
uh that we're seeing um and to me this
is just it's an incredible kind of state
overreach when we're not talking about
children ministers are are very clever
with their language at the moment you
know we don't want 14y olds to
smoke of course we don't want 14year
olds to smoke they shouldn't be smoking
they're not legally allowed to buy
cigarettes no no one's changing that no
one has changed that um we're talking
about when those 14-year-olds are 40
when they're 80 what are they allowed to
do
and we might have our opinions about
what we'd like them to do I'd love them
to be smoke free um are we allowed to
create a second tier of legal rights for
adults uh you and I will have different
rights from those future grown-ups and
I'm really uncomfortable with that yes
and I mean the real banter scenario for
this is that it goes to the ECR um you
know European Court human rights and
potentially could strike it down on the
grounds of you know is it fair to
discriminate for some citizens have some
certain rights and others not there a
lot of things that could go to the ECR
at the moment James it's a it's a big
topic right now um but I don't know this
you know I this just made me it made me
so angry to see um a Tor government that
uh you know could there's so much to be
done right now we need we need homes um
you know we we need some serious
planning reform uh we need to tackle the
tax burden we need to tackle spending
and you know I never thought I'd see a
day where hs2 or a huge part of it was
scrapped and I wouldn't be celebrating
but the the fact that the rabbit out of
the Hat on that in that same speech was
the smoking band made it made it near
impossible because the narrative which
is so confused I didn't really
understand what was trying to be
achieved here it was a policy that no
one's been asking for um it seemed more
like a pet peeve that needed to be
tackled and I'm just I wonder to myself
if you create a playbook for tackling
your pet paave what my other ministers
and other parties decide to use that
playbook for um I don't think it is
unrealistic to think that there are
other things that are are objectively
bad for us but that are obviously legal
in a free society that people might
start going after and so it led me to do
this really silly thing in Paris and you
know I I didn't bring back my pack of
Vogues I don't plan to like start
smoking every day by any means but it
was just my teeny tiny small Rebellion
against what I think um is is a much
much wider issue of where politics stops
and and free choice starts um of course
the critics will say you know you are
standing a th history here only 24% of
the British public agree uh in that they
oppose a you know a smokeless generation
Banning cigarettes at a certain point
what would you say to that I mean surely
there's the case that the Libertarians
frankly have just been unable to
convince any sway of the public to agree
with them on this given how many battles
they fought and lost this past decade
well look I uh I suppose what I would
say to that is that I'm not advocating
smoking right in any way I'm doing the
opposite you advocating the right to
choose I'm advocating the right to
choose and that right to choose applies
to smokers that is one teeny tiny
fraction of a personal private choice
that people might make every day I
believe in your right to choose what you
put anything you put into your body I
believe in your right to choose your own
drink I believe in your right uh to
choose your own partner I believe in
your right to have kids to not have kids
I believe in your right to walk down the
street unharmed I believe in all kinds
of Rights um and some of those things
you know we might all agree are good A
lot of those things will be contested
25% of the public want a nightclubs to
be shut permanently after the pandemic
there are a lot of people out there um
that will have varying degrees of what
they think is good behavior and what
isn't I suppose this is exactly my point
when you have politicians based on their
own preferences determine what they're
going determining what they're going to
ban and what they're not going to ban
you're in very dangerous territory so
this is not in any way about advocating
for one lifestyle or another it's saying
if you're not harming other people MH
should you be allowed to do something
and it's you know should be should be
very well noted that smoke smokers and
drinkers more than pay their way when it
comes to the Health Service the taxes
that we've brought in which by the way I
mean I don't think every taxes is spot
on but quite right that people pay for
um uh for the negative externalities
there uh every tax uh that we've brought
in means that smokers and drinkers are
more than paying their way I think it's
hard to argue that these people are
actively harming um other people
particularly when it comes to the NHS
and and and that's I think one of the
biggest arguments used by government so
this is not about condoning smoking in
any way I I very much hope as a
non-smoker
99.99999% of the time um that that the
next generation is smoke free they seem
to want to be I just want that to be a
choice that they make I want them to
proudly stand up and say yeah we're
rejecting this thing that's bad for me
don't want a politician doing it for
them and I certainly don't want a longer
and longer longer list of what we can
and cannot do it's a final question Kate
are you going to carry on with your your
smoking habit now I think it's really
unlikely James um because once again I
responded badly to substance I had the
cigarette um you know I I it felt it
felt sharp in my lungs it tasted great
it was a real mix bag experience I
passed out an hour later so it's just
not for me oh well thank you recovering
and joining us today on spectator TV
thank you that's it for this week once
again if you enjoy spectator TV do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon so
you never to miss another episode I'd
also like to thank our sponsors cancord
genuity wealth management cancord are
experienced wealth planners and
investment managers who offer unwavering
support during challenging times visit
CW wealth.com for more information
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next
[Music]
week